let f of x equal a times x to the n plus
b x plus 12 over
c times x to the m plus dx plus 12 where
m and n are integers and a b c and d are
unknown constants all right this is
interesting which of the following is a
process is a possible graph of y is
equal to f of x
and they tell us that dashed lines
indicate asymptotes and they give us
four choices here
and so i encourage you like always pause
this video give a go at it see if you
can figure out which of these graphs
could be the graph for y equals f of x
where f of x where they've given us this
information about f of x all right now
let's work through this again now this
is really interesting it's you know they
didn't give us a lot they didn't even
tell us what the exponents on x are they
haven't even given us the coefficients
all they've told all they've told us is
this 12 years so this 12 looks like a
pretty big clue so what can that tell us
the way they've written it we really
can't deduce any zeros for the function
we really can't deduce what x values
make the numerator equal zero or what x
values make the denominator equal zero
so it's going to be hard for us to
deduce what are the zeros of the
function or what are the removable
discontinuities or what are the vertical
asymptotes but just this 12 sitting here
does tell us one thing what happens when
x equals 0 because when x equals 0 every
other term
in this rational expression is just
going to be equal to zero and so we can
figure out f of zero f of zero is going
to be equal to well a times zero to the
n well that's just going to be 0
plus
b times 0 well that's just going to be 0
plus 12
over
c times 0 to the m power well that's
just going to be 0
d times 0 is going to be 0 and then we
have our 12 there so we're actually able
to figure out what f of 0 is it's 12
over 12
or
1.
so we actually know the y intercept for
this function let's see if that's enough
information for us to figure out if any
of these choices could be the graph of y
equals f of x
so let's see here so choice a
our y intercept is at two when x equals
0 our graph goes through 2 so we can
rule that out the y-intercept needs to
be 1.
so we can rule out let's see choice b
does have a y-intercept it looks like
just eyeballing it at 1 x equals 0 y is
1. so this looks interesting
choice c
has its y intercept at y is equal to
negative 1. so once again we can rule
that out
and choice d has no y intercept at all
so that was enough information and lucky
for us because they really didn't give
us a lot more information than just
being able to evaluate f of zero we
weren't able to figure out any of the
other you know the zeros or the vertical
asymptotes or the removable
discontinuities so we definitely feel
good about that choice